it's completely gone it's just
devastating
and the people that lost their houses
and everything is just
really heartbreaking
sheets of twisted metal and a blackened
carpet of ash the charred remains of
charlotte's stables
it stood no chance as it found itself in
the middle of yesterday's furnace
you're brushing them this was
three-year-old jody at the stables
recently with one of the horses who had
to be rescued now the surroundings are
unrecognizable
everything is completely gone burnt and
i mean absolutely thousands of pounds
worth of equipment that we use with our
animals that we've had for years and you
could not replace it but i can't replace
the life of the animals or the lives of
people so if that has to go first then
so be it
i'm very upset um you know it's now
sinking in that this has happened
it's like my our world has been turned
upside down
number 23 on the green has been the
akimphe family home for 16 years its
shell remains with severe smoke damage
but part of the garden has been
swallowed up
they say they're one of the lucky ones
when you go back to your street and you
see that you know four houses next to
yours is completely burnt down um you
know the whole the whole scenery
is very upsetting
stories of last night read like a
nightmare in dagenham four miles down
the road the scene of another wildfire
eileen couldn't bear the thought of
nearly losing her beloved dogs
luckily my ass is okay um
but there's a lot of people have lost
and we're not let back home yet so it's
emotion that has quickly turned to
action
donations from neighbours started last
night with a village of only 300
everyone knows someone impacted
whilst fire inspectors check if their
properties are salvageable residents
have been spending the night in
makeshift respite centres like this
sleeping on black mattresses and in
sleeping bags now we know some families
will be housed in hotel rooms for the
next three weeks
rebuilding properties and lives will
likely take years
this is really devastating for this
small community it's absolutely months
possibly into years really depends on
you know each situation as clearly as
we've seen some of the houses are
completely gone
the sickening reality for those unsure
when they'll be able to return home or
if they have something to return to
ashnahara next sky news in wellington